madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
moins de 50 ans après la première
traversée de l'atlantique nord voici que
concorde a ouvert aujourd'hui la
première ligne commerciale supersonique
entre l'europe et les états unis je vous
laisse d'ailleurs assister à ce moment
historique
l'atterrissage du concorde d'air france
sur l'aéroport foster dulles de
washington
vous voyez l'avion s'approche
il est posé
voilà quelques instants avant le
concorde d'air france le concorde de la
british airways s'était posé sur
l'aéroport de washington atterrissait
les premiers messieurs les anglais leur
atterrissage à pk blement réaliser les
deux appareils devaient s'immobiliser
nez à nez ou face à face ou si vous
aimez mieux bec à bec le concorde
français doit être de retour à roissy
sur l'aéroport charles de gaulle d'ici
trois quarts d'heure à peu près roissy
qu'il avait quittée cet après midi à
14h07 exploit qui se renouvellera
régulièrement maintenant et qui à s'en
tenir au plan technique se passe de tout
commentaire
si ce n'est loges
le monde politique est en pleine
effervescence deux phrases du président
de la république exploit explique cet
émoi la première concerne sa décision de
se maintenir à l'elysée en cas de
victoire de l'opposition élu pour sept
ans je resterai en fonction pendant ces
sept ans a déclaré valéry giscard
d'estaing que les français ont en effet
en 1974 bien élu pour sept ans
l'autre phrase se rapporte aux
propositions françaises d'envoyer des
troupes au liban pour y assurer la paix
entre les communautés et les factions si
les autorités libanaises le souhaite
bien entendu dans nos précédentes
éditions hier et avant-hier nous avons
largement traité de tout cela cependant
l'une des grandes formations politiques
françaises n'avaient pas fait connaître
sa position après les déclarations
présidentielles et pas la moindre
d'entre elles puisqu'il s'agit de lui dr
premiers partis politiques de la
majorité pour antenne 2 yves guéna le
secrétaire général de l'udps et r ce
silence l'un des partis de gauche avait
dit qu'en cas de victoire hypothétique
de la gauche aux élections de 1978 le
président devrait se soumettre ou se
démettre les communistes c'étaient les
communistes oui c'est une c'est une
formule qui est tout à fait inacceptable
car on ne peut pas dire que les
élections législatives et phase purement
et simplement le résultat des élections
présidentielles
donc le président a répondu en disant
non je ne me soumettrai pas non je ne me
permettrais pas il ya une troisième
solution qui est de rester et d' exercer
les prérogatives de président de la
république je crois que ça clarifie la
situation s'est pas tout à fait ce que
faisait le général de gaulle qui disait
s'ils voulaient pas derrière moi moi je
m'en vais pas du tout en ce qui concerne
les référendum le général a toujours
adopté cette attitude mais en ce qui
concerne les élections législatives il
n'a jamais dit ce qu'il ferait pour le
cas où le sort des urnes il serait
contraire leur autre petite phrase
importante du président le liban et
l'envoi éventuel de
troupes françaises on en a déjà beaucoup
parlé depuis trois jours et la réaction
générale et qu'on a l'impression que ça
a un peu manqué de préparation cette
déclaration ce que c'est votre avis s'il
ya eu un flottement dans le pignon c'est
je crois pas ce qu'est une mauvaise
interprétation et que certains ont pensé
qu'il y aurait une ingérence militaire
de la france dans les affaires
intérieures d'un état étranger c'était
tout à fait exclue mais la mise au point
du l'elysée à midi a été tout à fait
bienvenu en disant que nous
n'interviendrons que en qualité d'
espèce de casque bleu en quelque sorte
et pour assurer la paix sur le terrain
une fois que les parties se seraient mis
d'accord je crois qu'il faut replacer
donc la déclaration du président dans ce
cadre et à cet égard là il n'y a plus
aucune inquiétude av oui on n'en prend
pas tellement de chemin parce qu'elle
sur place a parlé les phalangistes
chrétiens et libanais eux-mêmes semblent
si réticents pour l'instant oui ça je ne
sais pas n'est ce pas on en prend
peut-être pas le chemin mais je m'excuse
je considère en bon gaulliste que la
politique étrangère c'est tout à fait la
sphère du président donc je me sens pas
autorisés à gloser sur les déclarations
du président et sur cette initiative on
verra
ce midi en effet le porte parole de
l'elysée monsieur xavier beauchamp avait
fait une mise au point sur la
possibilité d'une intervention militaire
française au liban pour préciser que
bien entendu il ne peut s'agir que d'une
intervention ne peut s'agir
pardonnez-moi d'une intervention armée
des forces militaires françaises mais
plutôt d'une opération du même type que
celle que l'onu a mené dans plusieurs
secteurs chauds du monde avec ses
casques bleus ne porte parole de
l'elysée a rappelé que de toute façon un
une telle opération serait très limité
dans le temps 2 qu'elle n'est
envisageable qu'après accord général de
l'opinion libanaise et des autorités
légales du pays il semble qu'on
attendait maintenant une réponse aux
propositions françaises de la part du
président de la république du liban
président élu monsieur sarr qui
la deuxième confédération syndicale
française tient depuis ce matin à annecy
son congrès c'est la cfdt congrès
préparée de longue date et qui constitue
un événement dans la mesure où la
centrale dennemont maire en pleine
mutation pourrait à l'issue de ce
congrès adopter de nouvelles
orientations aux côtés d'une cgt dont on
dit qu'elle se politise de plus en plus
c'est par exemple le point de vue
qu'exprime monsieur ceyrac le président
du cnpf la cfdt s'interroge elle aussi
doit l entretenir des relations
privilégiées avec un parti politique de
cela on débattra au congrès d'un si le
dernier congrès que tiendra la centrale
syndicale avant les élections
législatives débat qui compte tenu des
éléments quelquefois brûlant et souvent
contestataires qui constitue la cfdt
s'annonce comme serré
cette usine dans la banlieue de rouen
fabrique du matériel électrique et
électronique
une entreprise de taille moyenne 60
mille mètres carrés d'ateliers 18 ans
j'ai pris goût un travailleur sur 15 et
syndiqués la section cfdt regroupe l 260
militants jeunes pour la plupart à la
base un thème de réflexion commun à tous
ses adhérents l'autogestion
si tous les travailleurs d'une même
chaîne déterminer eux mêmes leur leurs
conditions de travail l'amélioration de
la prison de travail ce serait un
rapport mais d'effectifs que dans un
système comme on est pratiquement il
réalisa de la semaine dernière ça c'est
le patron qui prendra des décisions je
leur réponds à l'autogestion qu'est ce
que c'est
ma connaissance il n'y a pas de forme
actuellement exploité notre gestion par
conséquent je demande à voir mais j'ai
tendance à penser que ce qui est
important surtout c'est d'avoir une
bonne gestion pour vous ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire une gestion
intelligente raisonnable ce qui n'exclut
pas au contraire ce qui implique une
concertation
importante avec les syndicats notamment
avec les syndicats est un homme de vue
du terrain si j'ose dire depuis
longtemps j'ai pris l'habitude de
m'intéresser plus aux hommes qu'aux
étiquettes donc a fortiori il me
semblerait logique que
des candidatures libres puissent être
présentés si c'est la question que vous
posez
représentations ouvrière ça veut dire
que vous contestez le monopole syndical
je ne conteste pas
il me semble qu'il serait intelligent de
l'ouvrir
de langage donc au sein de l'entreprise
entre patrons et ouvriers au niveau de
l'action quotidienne un problème
fondamental
quelles sont les limites de l'action
syndicale
pour la cgt l'organisation syndicale
se limite assez rapidement aux parts de
l'entreprise alors que pour nous est
celle d'été on pense que la cfdt
prendre position sur tout ce qui
concerne la vie des travailleurs
en dehors de l'entreprise en dehors de
l'entreprise nation au niveau de la
région au niveau de la région on prend
je crois le moins des transports de
bovins du str et elle devant
l'entreprise on prend un but à la
sécurité de ce boulevard on prend pour
l'inde et de la pollution dans la région
rouennaise la cfdt se doit de s'exprimer
donner ses positions sur ces problèmes
là c'est ça regarde tous les autres tous
les travailleurs
pour la cfdt l'environnement de l'homme
au travail fait donc bien partie des
préoccupations du syndicat les
revendications ne s'arrête pas aux
portes de l'entreprise mais peut-on bien
faire toujours la différence entre
actions politiques et actions syndicales
et partis politiques ont un rôle bien
spécifique de soin de légiférer au
couteau prise du pouvoir c'est pas du
tout le but de la cfdt la cfdt elle à
être porteuse des aspirations des
travailleurs et de proposer des
revendications qui tienne compte de ses
aspirations tout une dimension de qui
aboutissent à un changement très
sérieuse mais votre objectif c'est bien
aussi de prendre le pouvoir au sein
d'une entreprise le charge de cet été
auprès de l'entreprise ont passé au
niveau des travailleurs que
l'irresponsabilité devons être prêts ils
se séparent sur les cas qui prendra le
pouvoir des entreprises de gestion si
bien apprise du pouvoir enfin faire les
travailleurs par l'intermédiaire d'un
syndicat le syndicat aura un rôle bien
spécifique dans quelques sociétés qu'on
soit neutre le syndicat doit garder son
rôle de contestation ou bouddha peur
mais de garder son rôle devient autonome
de contestation même dans une société
socialiste on pense que pour éviter que
des abus qu'il peut y avoir le syndicat
doit garder son autonomie pleine et
entière il y avait des bonnes choses
autant pour l'album mais la cfdt a donné
son avis là dessus de garder son
indépendance à l'égard de quelques
doubles quelque gouvernement que cela
soit la même de gauche
la cfdt doit elle rester une force
originale au sein de l'union de la
gauche ou bien sera t-elle la courroie
de transmission du parti socialiste les
militants trancheront aux compagnies si
l'iran confiera la france la
construction de deux centrales
nucléaires et maintient ses options sur
trois concorde mais la commande dépend
pas de la rentabilité de l'appareil le
premier ministre iranien qui est arrivé
aujourd'hui à paris l'a confirmé ce soir
après son premier entretien avec
monsieur jacques chirac
la police est intervenue ce matin la
faculté des lettres de montpellier où
une soixantaine de manifestants
s'opposaient au déroulement des examens
briques vitraux jets de cocktails
molotov les examens perturbés ont été
reporté au 12 juin prochain
un hélicoptère et sa 330 puma de l'armée
de l'air française s'est écrasé ce matin
au cours d'un exercice de combat près de
djibouti si légionnaires et de
sous-officiers ont trouvé la mort dans
cet accident
considéré comme l'un des plus éminents
urologue français le professeur firent
aboulker est mort cet après-midi à paris
à la suite d'un malaise cardiaque âgé de
70 ans il avait opéré le général de
gaulle en avril 64
les douaniers de l'aéroport d'orly ont
saisi hier 100 kilos de haschich en
claquettes représentant une valeur
globale de 2 millions de francs la
drogue était convoyé par un couple
d'allemands débarquer d'agde ali
20 et non 19 nouveaux cardinaux
aujourd'hui au vatican pool6 a révélé ce
matin que l'archevêque de hanoi est l un
des deux prélats dont il avait gardé le
nom secret le collège des cardinaux
compte à ce jour 128 mende dont 120
éliront le futur pain
à la cour de sûreté de l'état a repris
ce matin le procès du docteur simeoni
considéré comme l'un des responsables de
la fusillade d'aléria qui devait
provoquer la mort de deux gendarmes
comme la semaine dernière ce sont encore
des témoins de la défense qui
aujourd'hui ont été entendus par la cour
et comme la semaine dernière autant que
la fusillade c'est le scandale du vin
qui avait provoqué la colère des
militants autonomistes qui a été au
centre des débats demain avec le début
des dépositions des témoins de
l'accusation les choses devraient
changer et le procès prendre une
nouvelle direction le docteur simioni et
ses amis rejettent depuis le début du
procès la responsabilité de tout ce qui
est arrivé sur le pouvoir central
représenté par le préfet qui a donné
l'ordre d'encercler puis de prendre
d'assaut la cave de paix les autorités
citées vont essayer bien entendu au
contraire de montrer que la montée de la
violence ne pouvait que déboucher sur un
affrontement et que s'agissant des
événements d'aléria il était impossible
de laisser agir librement des militants
autonomistes armée est enfermé avec des
otages dans une propriété privée c'est
la confrontation de ces deux thèses mais
c'est le coeur du procès bien sûr qui
risque de faire monter le temps
jusqu'à présent les débats se sont
déroulés disons dans le calme et même la
courtoisie le président david et
l'avocat général ont laissé le docteur
simeoni s'expliquer longuement et
intervenir constamment dans le
déroulement des interrogatoires et cette
première semaine a montré que le leader
de l'arc était un véritable tribun pour
la corse brillant et passionné pour sa
cause mais un leader plutôt modérée est
en tout cas responsable cette semaine a
montré aussi qu'il sera bien difficile
d'imputer aux accusés la mort des
gendarmes puisque tout le monde admet
maintenant y compris l'avocat général
que les tirs meurtriers ont pu venir
aussi bien des vignes que de la cave
enfin si l'on voulait schématiser on
pourrait dire que cette première partie
du procès a plutôt été al'avantage de la
défense mais vous le savez le procès est
loin d'être terminée
les amoureux du paquebot france vont
être mortifié la cunard de la compagnie
de navigation britannique à qui
appartient le queen elizabeth
le dernier grand transatlantique encore
en service s'en va clamant qu'elle fait
des bénéfices avec son paquebot est
quand même à 5 millions de centimes bien
sûr la croisière ces cabines de luxe
sont occupés pour la compagnie
britannique
l'exploitation d'un super paquebots
comme les j'allais dire comme l'était le
france est donc rentable rentabilité que
la compagnie générale transatlantique
quant à elle a jugé irréaliste pour ce
qui concerne le france puisque nous ne
savons pas l'exploiter d'une manière
rentable il faut donc trouver un
acquéreur au transatlantique français
qui risquent de rouiller à son quai du
havre chaque semaine on parle
d'acquéreurs potentiels mais rien
jusqu'ici de concret et il est à
craindre que le paquebot france finisse
comme le queen mary le queen mary
transformé en hôtel et en centre
d'attraction et que l'un des envoyés
spéciaux d'antenne 2 aux états unis nous
fait maintenant visite
dans la ville de long beach non loin de
los angeles et rue font un détour pour
éviter les puits de pétrole la
municipalité touche un pourcentage sur
les bénéfices de l'or noir et ses pompes
lui ont permis de s'offrir le queen mary
2 millions de francs
aujourd'hui il est ancré à jamais le
long d'une langue de terre spécialement
construite pour lui et comme s'il avait
la velléité de rejoindre le large on l'a
entourée d'une digue le queen mary
construit en 1936 est venu s'échouer ici
en 1968 après trois ans il était ouvert
au public un hôtel de 400 chambres vous
pourrez toucher dans le même lit que
greta garbo ou clarkdale il ne manquera
que le roulis gratuitement vous pourrez
vous promener sur les ponts supérieurs
et pour 2 $ vous suivre un circuit
organisé salle des machines poste de
commande
et surtout vous pourrez voir comment des
milliers d'américains sont rentrés au
pays à la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
beaucoup d'américains viennent
aujourd'hui à bord pour se souvenir
et la principale attraction demeure le
musée de la mer le musée cousteau
éducation & recreation toujours mêlé aux
états unis en apprend aux enfants les
animaux les plantes de la mer
pour aménager une pluie de merrill a
fallu gratter la peinture trois cent
soixante tonnes de peinture ont été
enlevés dégager la salle des machines
les travaux ont coûté 75 millions de
francs
se structure extrêmement difficile a
aménagé un bateau se comporte comme une
poutre à partir du moment où vous
affaiblissez la structure de la poutre
vous arrivez une catastrophe en cas d'un
bateau ce encore pire parce que vous
pouvez pas pousser les murs on peut pas
pousser la coke c'est très très
difficile à faire alors si très très
cher c'est très très cher je crois que
là la valeur de l'idée du queen mary
c'est que d'abord c'était le queen mary
c'est un bateau historique pour les
américains en particulier et ensuite si
vous voulez c'était unique
je crois que s'il fallait refaire un
programme similaire au programme des
queen mary secret beaucoup moins cher de
le démarrer de zéro
plutôt que d'essayer d'aménager un
bateau il est évident que l'aménagement
du puy mary a coûté trop cher on dit
même que certains millions de dollars
ont disparu dans quelques aux troubles
cher car c'était la première fois qu'on
tentait une telle expérience
pour le france on pourrait diviser le
prix par deux les plus modernes mieux
agencé et pourrait bénéficier de
l'expérience de queen mary
la seule section qui rapportent de
l'argent les mariages pour 350 francs
vous serez baigner en mer si ce n'est au
large car la sphère queen mary n'est
toujours pas rentable simplement au lieu
d'un jardin public la municipalité de
long beach offre un après-midi sur le
queen mary
le queen mary exemple pour le france
difficile car derrière le bateau anglais
on trouve une population de 10 millions
dans un rayon de 100 kilomètres
peut-être pour le france la côte d'azur
mais un était seulement de toute façon
impossible d'envisager une opération
rentable
je pense que faire un musée ce serait
très difficile sur un plan commercial il
est certain qu'il faudrait que ce soit
une opération sans but lucratif
il est possible aussi d entrevoir la
possibilité de faire par exemple une
université je crois que vous pourriez
combiné à centre universitaire un centre
de recherche et un centre muséologique
c'est à mon avis la meilleure chance
cole france pourrait avoir
le queen mary la grand-mère du franc la
grand mère a trouvé preneur la petite
fille se morfond du côté du havre il est
vrai qu'elle n'a plus de dot et qu'elle
est très dépensière
et bien aussi attractif que soit ce
queen mary à la retraite rien ne vous
croyez moi à un paquebot qui croisent
sur la mer
aujourd'hui il a fait chaud avec souvent
plus de 20 degrés sur la france 24 25
degrés du côté de la vallée de la loire
à l'exception cependant du béarn et du
pays basque où on a observé des baisses
très importante de température comme
vous pouvez en juger avec notre carte
demain le beau temps cessera des nuages
accompagnés de pluies éparses et
d'orages parfois violents
atteindront le matin la normandie le
berry et l'aquitaine également le soir
le nord le bassin parisien les alpes et
le roussillon ce temps perturbé sera
précédé un ciel plus nuageux et suivies
par un temps variable sur l'ouest tandis
que les températures subiront une baisse
sensible c'est à neutre
au cours de cette soirée antenne 2 à
partir de 21h50 vous présentera une
émission spéciale sur le vietnam un an
après la victoire du viet congs c'est un
document de tout premier ordre le
premier de ce genre depuis que le
vietnam du sud est entrée totalement
dans le monde communiste je vous engage
à le regarder ce film sera suivi d'un
débat que dirigera jean marie cavada et
qui mettra en présence un journaliste
américain de l'a6b est notre confrère de
l'aurore pierre d'harcourt et jean
lacouture du nouvel observateur ce film
et ce débat nous mèneront jusqu'à 23h20
heure à laquelle gérard holtz vous
présentera la dernière édition de notre
journal bonne soirée donc sur antenne 2
ça s'impose et à demain